R
HARD WORK.
>> THANK YOU, JESSE.
>> Jesse: LET'S TURN OVER TO
FORMER U.N. AMBASSADOR AND
AUTHOR OF "IF YOU WANT SOMETHING
DONE" NIKKI HALEY.
SO, AMBASSADOR, YOU HEARD THIS
EXPERT UP THERE SAYING THAT
WE'RE INVOLVED IN MASSIVE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, GOVERNMENT IS
PAYING FOR IT.
THE CHINESE ARE FUNDING SOME OF
IT.
AND THE UNITED NATIONS IS FULLY
AWARE OF WHAT IS GOING ON.
YOU WERE AT THE U.N.
WHAT THE HELL IS GOING ON HERE?
>> WELL, THE U.N. IS USELESS.
WE KNOW THAT BUT, AT THE END OF
THE DAY, THIS ALL FALLS ON
BIDEN.
AND IT'S UNTHINKABLE WHAT HE IS
ALLOWING TO HAVE HAPPEN.
AND I WILL TELL YOU, WHEN WE WIN
IN NOVEMBER, THE HOUSE AND
SENATE, THE FIRST BILL THEY NEED
TO PUT ON HIS DESK, HAS TO BE
SOMETHING RELATED TO THE BORDER.
THEY HAVE GOT TO MAKE HIM DO
SOMETHING.
THIS IS ABUSIVE ON SO MANY
LEVELS.
EVERY STATE IS NOW A BORDER
STATE.
WE ARE SEEING IT IN YOU ARE
OSCHOOLS.
WE ARE SEEING IN OUR HOSPITALS.
NOW YOU ARE SEEING IT
TRAFFICKING AND PRESSURES ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
IT'S JUST WRONG.
>> Jesse: CAN PEOPLE IN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BE
CRIMINALLY CHARGED FOR BEING
INVOLVED IN SOMETHING AS SICK AS
THIS?
>> THIS IS TOTALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE.
>> Jesse: THEY HAVE LOST 20,000
KIDS.
>> IT'S UNTHINKABLE AND AT SOME
POINT IT'S GOING TO COME TO
LIGHT WHAT'S HAPPENED AND THEY
NEED TO PAY THE PRICE FOR IT.
THIS IS TERRIBLE.
>> Jesse: IF A WOMAN WAS IN
CHARGE AND YOU BRING THIS UP IN
YOUR BOOK ASK A WOMAN.
I THINK MARGARET THATCHER THAT
WAS HER LINE.
WHAT WOULD WOMEN DO DIFFERENTLY.
>> MARGARET IF YOU WANT
SOMETHING SAID ASK A MAN IF YOU
WANT SOMETHING DONE ASK A WOMAN.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE NEED TO
GET RESULTS.
THE BOOK IS ABOUT ORDINARY WOMEN
WHO BECAME EXTRAORDINARY.
BECAUSE THEY HAD COURAGE.
BECAUSE THEY WERE
PROBLEM-SOLVERS, BECAUSE THEY
WANTED TO GET THINGS DONE.
AND SO FOR EVERY PARENT THAT HAS
A CHILD OR KNOWS A YOUNG
PROFESSIONAL, YOU KNOW, THIS IS
MOTIVATION AND INSPIRATION TO
SAY, YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE GOT
THIS, KEEP GOING WE NEED YOU.
AND TO GET THEM OUT THERE AND
START DOING SOMETHING.
>> Jesse: I HAVE TWIN GIRLS AND
MAKE THEM READ.
THIS THERE WILL BE A TEST
AFTERWARDS.
THANK YOU FOR WRITING IT.
HAVE YOU SEEN A LOT OF FOOTAGE
WOMEN BEING BRUTALIZED IN OUR
CITIES.
OBVIOUSLY WOMEN EVEN GIRLS BEING
TRAFFICKED BY OUR OWN
GOVERNMENT.
WHY DON'T YOU HEAR MORE FROM THE
FEMINIST LEFT ABOUT THAT.
>> THE NEW FEMINISM THAT I TALK
ABOUT IS NOT VIC HOOD.
IT'S TAKING THINGS INTO YOU'RE
OWN HANDS.
WE GOT A CHANCE TO DO THAT IN
NOVEMBER.
HOUSE RACES AND SENATE RACES AND
GUBERNATORIAL RACES.
YOU SEE THE CRIME ON THE SUNWAYS
HERE IN NEW YORK CITY.
PARENTS SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT WHETHER THEIR CHILD CAN
RIDE THEIR BIKE DOWN THE STREET
OR WHETHER THEY ARE GOING TO GET
MUGGED OR CAR JACKED IF THEY GO
INTO A RESTAURANT.
YOU LOOK AT THE BORDER AND THE
IDEA THAT WE HAVE HAD ENOUGH
PEOPLE CROSS THAT BORDER SINCE
BIDEN TOOK OFFICE THAT WOULD
CREATE THE THIRD LARGEST CITY IN
AMERICA IRRESPONSIBLE AND WRONG
AND COME NOVEMBER HALF THE
BATTLE IS WINNING MORE IMPORTANT
IS HALF THE BATTLE IS PROVING WE
NEED TO BE THERE WHEN WE WIN.
>> Jesse: WE CAN'T RUN THE
CITIES THAT WE DO I DON'T